.
OFFICIALS, NOW, CHECKING OTHER
BUILDINGS IN THE AREA, TO
ENSURE THAT COMPLY WITH ALL
FIRE SAFETY STANDARDS.
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ABOUT
CHINA'S SABER RATTLING AGAINST
TAIWAN, IN RECENT WEEKS,
INCLUDING MILITARY FLIGHTS,
NEAR THE ISLAND, AND LANDING
DRILLS, ACROSS THE CITY.
BUT, WE NOW WANT TO SHOW YOU
ANOTHER SIDE OF THIS EQUATION,
TAKING YOU TO THE STREETS OF
TAIPEI, WHERE THE ATTITUDE OVER
CHINA'S INTIMIDATION CAMPAIGN
IS, FOR SOME, NO BIG DEAL.
WILL RIPLEY, JOINING US NOW,
FROM TAIWAN'S CAPITAL, TO
EXPLAIN.
WILL, THERE HAS BEEN THIS SHARP
RHETORIC FROM CHINA.
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE USED
TO, BUT THERE HAS BEEN A BIT OF
AN ESCALATION, AS YOU POINTED,
OUT IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
I GUESS, THE QUESTION IS, ARE
THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN WORRIED?
THE >> PUT IT TO YOU THIS WAY.
THE STORY YOU JUST REPORTED
ABOUT THE FIRE, IN SOUTHERN
TAIWAN, IS A MASSIVE STORY,
HERE.
THROUGH THE RECORD NUMBER OF
WARPLANES, AND IT IS THOSE IN
THE NEWS, AND PEOPLE HERE ARE,
FRANKLY, DESENSITIZE TO IT.
IT FEELS TO THEM, ALMOST LIKE
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND THE
PRESIDENT BEGAN REPORTING THIS
INFORMATION ONLY A YEAR AGO.
BUT, IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT
CHINA IS SAYING NOW, AND YOU
LISTEN TO THE GLOBAL TIMES
EDITORIAL THAT SAID, CHINA IS,
STILL, SEEKING A PEACEFUL
SOLUTION, AS LONG AS THAT
PEACEFUL SOLUTION ENDS WITH THE
REUNIFICATION OF TAIWAN, WITH
THE MAINLAND.
THEN, YOU CAN SEE, THE
DIFFICULT POSITION TAIWAN IS IN,
AND THE GROWING MILITARY THAT,
THEY ARE UP AGAINST.
>> CHINESE SOLDIERS, TRAINED
FOR THE INVASION OF TAIWAN.
A NEW PROPAGANDA VIDEO, SHOWING
AN AMPHIBIOUS ASSAULT.
BEIJING, SAYS THIS EXERCISE
TARGETS TAIWAN, INDEPENDENCE.
AND, INTERFERENCE, BY EXTERNAL
FORCES, LIKE THE U.S..
A WARNING FOR PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN, AND OTHER U.S. ALLIES,
WHO CONTINUE TO VOICE SUPPORT
IN TAIWAN.
THERE ARE LOOKING FOR RECORD
HIGHS, ON TAIWAN'S DEFENSE
MINISTER SAYS CHINA COULD
LAUNCH A FULL SCALE WAR, BY
2025.
HE SAYS, MILITARY TENSIONS ARE
THE WORST, AND MORE THAN 40
YEARS.
THE MAINLAND'S MASSIVE ARMY,
POSING A GROWING THREAT, TO THE
WORLD'S ONLY CHINESE SPEAKING
DEMOCRACY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU A QUICK
QUESTION.
>> ON THE STREETS OF TAIWAN, WE
GET A SENSE OF THE MOOD ON THE
GROUND.
IT IS NOT WHERE YOU MIGHT THINK.
>> CHINA'S FOR A LONG TIME,
THEY WANT TO TAKE OVER TAIWAN,
BUT MAYBE JUST SAYING, WE DON'T
KNOW.
WE ARE STILL HERE.
>> LUIS YOUNG OWNS A SMALL
BURGER RESTAURANT, HE BELIEVES
TAIWAN AS A COUNTRY, HIS
COUNTRY, NOT PART OF CHINA.
TO SHOP OWNER MOVED WHO THINKS
THE U.S. MILITARY SHOULD
INTERVENE.
>> I THINK THE UNITED STATES
HAS TO HELP, BECAUSE OF TAIWAN
STRATEGIC POSITION.
AS LONG AS TAIWAN DOES NOT GIVE
UP ON ITSELF, AND HAS A STRONG
DEFENSIVE SENSIBILITY.
I THINK THE U.S. CAN DEFINITELY
HELP.
>> THIS MONTH CHINA FLEW
RECKONING OF WARPLANES NEAR
TAIWAN, INCLUDING FIGHTER JETS
A NUCLEAR CAPABLE BOMBERS.
BEIJING HAS NEVER RULED OUT
TAKING TAIWAN BY.
FORCE INSISTING THE ISLAND IS
PART OF MAINLAND CHINA.
EVEN THOUGH IT HAS ITS OWN
GOVERNMENT AND MILITARY, MORE
THAN 70 YEARS AFTER CHINA'S
CIVIL WAR.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
70 YEARS THAT CHINA HAS >> THE
MILITARY, AND THE GOVERNMENT,
IS NOT RECOGNIZED BY BEIJING.
THEY'RE OUT SPENDING THEM AND
DEFENSE BY 15 TIMES, THIS TIME
WANTS BILLIONS TO HIS DEFENSE
BUDGET, BECAUSE BILLIONS OF
WEAPONS, AND CLOSER TIES THAT
ARE, SEEMING, TO AGITATE
BEIJING EVEN FURTHER.
AND, MAKING THESE VERY,
INCREASINGLY, BOLD STATEMENTS,
THAT THE REUNIFICATION, IN
THEIR, WORDS OF THE MAINLAND
AND TAIWAN, AS ALL BUT
INEVITABLE.
REUNIFICATION IS NOT A WORD
THEY USE IN TAIPEI, BECAUSE
THEY SAY, HOW CAN YOU REUNIFY
WHEN THE ISLAND OF TAIWAN, WITH
ITS GOVERNMENT, IT WAS NEVER
RULED BY THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC
OF CHINA, WITH ITS GOVERNMENT?
THEY HAVE BEEN TO, SEPARATE, AT
LEAST IN THE VIEW OF THE
LEADERSHIP IN TAIPEI, FOR MORE
THAN 70 YEARS.
IT, MEASURABLE RECORD OF THE
GOVERNMENT HERE, AND TAKEN THE
ISLAND BACK BY FORCE.
ASSERTING TO SOME ANALYSTS,
THEY NOW HAVE AN ISLAND IN
MAINLAND CHINA THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY DO IT.
IT MAY NOT TAKE AS LONG AS YOU
THINK.
>> AND TO PUT A FINE POINT ON
AND I DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE
ENVISIONED WHAT HAPPENED IN
HONG KONG, IN THE LAST, FIGURES
HAPPENING AS IT DID.
SO, AGAIN YOU, UNDERSTAND WHY
MANY ANALYSTS ARE ON EDGE.
EVEN IF THE PEOPLE OF TAIWAN,
PERHAPS, ARE NOT AT THIS HOUR.
>> AND I WANT TO, SORRY, I JUST
WANT TO SAY, ON THAT POINT, YOU
POINTED OUT A GOOD THING.
IN HONG KONG, IT WAS THE STROKE
OF A PEN THAT CHANGE THAT CITY,
MORE THAN ROLLING TANKS THROUGH
THE STREETS OVER COULD.
THERE IS A DISINFORMATION
WARFARE CAMPAIGN, BEING WAGED
IN TAIPEI, AS WELL.
BASICALLY, FAKES NEWS STORIES
ARE BEING PLANTED INTO THIS
COUNTRY, WITH ONE OF THE
WORLD'S FREE INSTANT TURN, IT'S
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU GET ENOUGH PEOPLE
BELIEVING THE FAKE NEWS, THEY
COULD VOTE IN A GOVERNMENT THAT
BEIJING WANTS.
A GOVERNMENT THAT, ESSENTIALLY,
CAN MAKE BEIJING FEEL LIKE YOU
WOULD BE EASIER TO REUNIFY.
>> IT IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POINT, AS YOU SAID.
THE STROKE OF A, PAN DOING IT,
AND CONTINUES TO DO TH